[Music]
for thousands of years we've used bells
to make noise the concept behind them is
simple a clapper or hammer strikes the
bell wall creating vibrations that
disturb the air the disturbance causes
the ringing sound it's not high-tech but
it can be high-pitched every Bell has a
distinctive ring from the festive jingle
of sleigh bells to the clang of the
boxing Bell that marks the beginning of
a fight even the cowbell has a sound
that's not quite like any other the
bells shape and the material it's made
from affect the Rings pitch to make a
cowbell an assembler uses two flared
steel components to form a cone he
inserts a handle between the two parts
at the top and welds the seams of the
bell shell to hold the two parts
together then he welds the handle to the
cowbell body the handle contains a small
loop that extends inside the Bell body
to hold the clapper this strip of steel
is about to be transformed into sleigh
bells an upper die forces the steel
strip and two dies on a rotating platter
the dies form the metal into a shape
that resembles an open flower ball
bearings fall into a chute the ball
bearings land in the open flowers on the
platter the upper die closes the petals
of the flower creating a round sleigh
bell the rattle of the interior ball
bearing will create the sound a device
pops the bell out of the die and the
sleigh bells fall into a bin
once the sleigh bells are plated with
nickel they are ready for rattling at
another station a boxing Bell begins to
take shape an assembler transfers the
Bell to a punch that cuts a hole in the
center the punch forces it onto a form
that contours the area around the hole
oil keeps the metal lubricated as it's
forming the gongs tumble around in a
machine with vibrating ceramic stones
detergent and water the stones scrub off
the oil and rub off rough edges after
about 10 minutes the gongs emerged
smooth and clean they land in the tub of
ground corn cobs
the corn absorbs any residual water as
it pulsates in this vibratory machine a
technician places the gongs in an oven
this heat treatment rearranges the
crystalline structures of the steel and
hardens it making the steel more
Brazilian will also make the Gong sound
more resonant when struck
the gums are sprayed with the powder
coating when baked on the powder
particles will form a protective skin on
the metal and provide the gongs with the
uniform finish a powder coat is sprayed
on the Belle's base plate and an
adhesive back company logo is applied to
the back posts have been installed on
the front for assembling the other parts
a brass lever for operating the bell
hammer and the mechanism that will swing
it called a dog the assembler rivets the
dog to the lever and hooks one end of a
spring to the mechanism he fastens
another spring to the hammer and then
hooks the end to the base plate he
installs the hammer on one of the posts
using a push nut he secures the hammer
to the post he hooks the lever spring on
the base plate and slides the lever on
to a post just under the hammer
another push nut locks the lever in
place the assembler pulls the lever
examining the movement adjusting
accordingly
he now adds the gone aligning the center
hole to the threaded post in the middle
of the back plate he screws on a
fastener to hold the Gong in place he
pulls the lever to confirm that the
hammer hits the gun and makes a noise
finally this boxing Bell is now ready
for the ring